don't you know who this is
she was thinking of something more
special i'm downright flashy you know
ladies and gentlemen miss billy holliday
reporters keep asking me really why you
do the things you do
this is what i tell them i love me
we love you why not
take care and the blessing says billy
holiday is the voice
of our people i think we should
integrate the audience with this show
change it up a little bit you know
blacks and whites sitting together
[Music]
you know what you're getting yourself
into when you decide to come on the road
get out my goddamn i'm close
i'm gonna take everything except your
bra and your name
which one of my songs is your favorite
song strange fruit
yeah it's a song about important things
you know things that are going on in the
country
it's holiday is causing a lot of people
to think the wrong things
it's a starting gun for this so-called
civil rights movement those lyrics
provoke people y'all got a plan she's a
drug addict
exactly i cut strange fruit
i want to sing the damn song it's for
your own good okay
i said what the [ __ ] i want
[Music]
get her off trees stage
they're strange
fruit they won't let me sing nowhere no
clubs no money no nothing
you gotta understand baby right now i'm
in a situation look you said we could
beat this building i need some now
blood on the leaves you're like a hammer
come right back and it hit harder than
before
he's singing it for all of us ain't no
other negro star
bold enough to do it
black bodies swinging i'm being followed
i'm not going to count in no faith
she's made something of herself and you
can't take it because she's strong
beautiful and black
[Music]
strange
trees
[Music]
i think i'm gonna stop singing that song
you grandkids will be singing strange
[Music]
fruit
you